hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
lactancias is a Christian philosopher
which means on the one hand that he is a
Christian and his Christian faith is
going to be drawn upon and incorporated
into his philosophical activity but that
he is also recognizing that philosophy
has contributions to make and that it's
important that he engaged with the you
know array of philosophical positions
and perspectives and thinkers that have
preceded him for hundreds of years and
in the very beginning of his Treatise on
the anger of God he is going to provide
us with a kind of formulation of the
project that he is engaged in which
connects him with other philosophers who
are not Christians so he talks about out
the human condition as such at the very
beginning and he says that you know
there's many people that hold this
opinion which some philosophers have
maintained God is Not subject to anger
and then he starts giving some you know
reasonings there and he says the error
of these people tends to overthrow the
condition of human life and we need to
refute it so what's going on here he
says that we're not so arrogant as to
boast that the truth is comprehended
like grasped as a totality by our
intellect our intellectual capacities
quite literally but we follow the
teaching of God who alone is able to
know and reveal secret things so God
comes in to help out and he says
following that the philosophers being
destitute of this teaching they are
going astray why
because the mind of the human being
right the human mind as he says enclosed
in the dark Abode of the the body he
actually uses the word for shadowy here
tenebrosis right so the human mind is
inevitably connected with the body he'll
talk about this at greater length in
later chapters
and because of that
can it perceive truth well I mean
obviously some truths are very easy to
perceive through the body like that this
chalk is white or if I was going to bite
down on it then it's not good to eat
right but when it comes to the things
that matter more particularly matters of
God or the soul or The providential
Ordering of the world or our emotions
well it's not quite so easy for us and
we often do in fact make mistakes so
that is part of the human condition
right off the bat right we're removed
from the perception of truth then we've
got a second problem here if we're going
to be thinking about God and anger the
main topic of the treaties the divine
nature is distanced or differs from the
human nature right literally what he's
saying there in the Latin is divinitas
is different than humanitas
and because of that we we look at
ourselves and we can understand
ourselves quite fine but extrapolating
to God that's a bit trickier Now isn't
it and so you know we also have a
correlation here the divine nature is
knowledgeable it possesses skientia true
knowledge of things whereas we're so
marked by a lack of knowledge ignorance
what we translate as ignorance which is
including of ourselves and of the Divine
so what can we do here he says
on account of this we have some need of
light to dispel the darkness by which
the reflection of human beings is
overspread while we live in our mortal
flesh we're unable to Divine by our
senses but well what is this the light
of the human mind is God he who is known
and admitted him into his breast will
acknowledge the mystery of Truth with an
enlightened heart but when God in
Heavenly instruction are removed things
are full of Errors we make all sorts of
mistakes and here he brings up
interestingly the example of Socrates
and we do have to say this is not the
real Socrates this is the portrait of
Socrates that the Skeptics like to put
forward oh I don't know anything at all
right so but there is something valuable
in this he says Socrates though he was
the most learned of all the philosophers
yet that he might prove the ignorance of
the others who thought they possess
something rightly said he knew nothing
except one thing that he knew nothing
for he understood that learning had
nothing certain nothing true in itself
nor as some imagine did he pretend to
learning that he might refute others but
he saw the truth in some measure and he
testified even on his trial that there
was no human wisdom I mean is this
really accurate well let conscious is
playing a little fast and loose but you
get the idea here at least some people
can in a kind of humility say that they
don't know everything and that
philosophy can't provide the entire
truth about stuff and may need some help
so he is going to tell us in the passage
that I I skipped over very quickly that
philosophers
being destitute of of the teaching of
God have imagined the nature of things
naturally
can be ascertain and by as he calls it
conjecture right it's just a
transliteration of that term and we can
give a few examples in here of that you
know a little bit later on he will talk
about epicurus having made one
questionable assumption and then because
of that not realizing it getting drawn
into a whole set of mistaken
assumptions have to do with the emotions
namely that if you've got one emotion
you've got the whole register of human
emotions and lactancia says well not
even really true for human beings but if
we think this through we can see that
that's not the case for God so you know
conjecture can get you into trouble he
talks at another point about the stoics
having gone wrong and giving all sorts
of mistaken definitions of anger as a
result because they fail to see the
distinction between just or good anger
and unjust or bad anger they just treat
it all here's a conjecture all anger is
unjust right so once you make these
sorts of conjectures or assumptions
which you do because you know how else
are you going to proceed well you go
astray right
what could we do by contrast so in
chapter two
locked on CS is going to tell us about
the steps to you know genuine knowledge
and these are uh grados right or grandus
these are you could say gradations or
stages whatever you want to translate
them as so he says there's many steps by
which the ascent is made to the Abode of
truth it's not easy for anyone to reach
the summit why because when the eyes are
darkened by the brightness of the truth
they who are unable to maintain a firm
step fall back to level ground so
there's something about some of the
objects that we're studying you know
particularly God as we approach them are
the eyes of our mind are dazzled by them
and so we have to as we're going up one
step to the next we have to make sure
that we're firmly on the step because if
we don't what's going to happen he
actually is going to talk about falling
back to ruin win right
is the Latin there so these are things
that not only do we have to make the
step we have to consolidate the step so
what are these three steps he says the
first step is to understand false
religions and throw aside the impious
worship of gods which are made by the
hand of human beings so uh essentially
you know understand the falseness of
false religions and reject the worship
of Idols or a Dollar Tree right that's
what idolatry means latria service of
worship of Idols things that human
beings create we'll look at what that
means in just a moment What's the Second
Step he says that
it's to perceive with the mind that
there is but one supreme god whose power
in Providence made the world from the
beginning and afterwards continues to
govern it so you know this is telling
you some things about the nature of God
engaging in essentially rational
theology right although it could be
coming from scriptural passages or
people telling you things with testimony
right and then step three is
distinctively Christian we could say the
third step is to know his servant and
messenger or Herald right who he sent as
his ambassador to the Earth by whose
teaching being freed of the error in
which we were held entangled and formed
to the worship of the true God we might
learn righteousness so you know there's
um you could call it getting rid of
long-headed ideas than making your way
to understanding that there is a God and
what God is like and then finally a
third step of you know we could call it
consolidation through this mediator of
of Christ right and so he goes on with
each of these and he says
we see those shaken off from the first
step who though they understand things
that are false don't discover that which
is true
though they despised Earthly and frail
images they do not but take themselves
to the worship of The God Who they're
ignorant so this would include some of
the you know atheistic or agnostic
philosophers of the past who you know
he's going to mention a little bit later
on who say yeah yeah yeah that ancient
Greek religion that's all Bs but they
don't have anything to put in its place
right so that's a problem and he goes on
and he says
there's others who
um you know view with admiration the
elements of the universe and they
worship the heaven or the Earth the sea
the Sun the moon other heavenly bodies
and that's a problem right and he says
you know we've already talked about this
in the Divine institutes I don't need to
go into that anymore
the Second Step he says there are those
who fall from it because they understand
that there is one supreme god but
ensnared by the philosophers captivated
by false arguments they entertain
opinions concerning that far removed
from the truth and so what are some of
these well they deny that God has any
figure or think that he is moved by no
affection because every affection is a
sign of weakness
um so you know that's that's going to be
a problem and that is really going to be
what he's going to talk about here as
well we'll see but then there's the
third step right so how do people get to
and then fall away from the third step
he tells us that they know the
ambassador of God who is also the
builder of the Divine and Immortal
Temple but either they don't receive him
or they receive him otherwise than Faith
demands and we've also talked about this
in you know the Divine in institutes
this leads to various sects which have
destroyed the truth so here he's not
really thinking about philosophers as
such as he is at step two and step one
he's thinking more about
um unorthodox versions of Christianity
that make of this Christ figure
something other than what Orthodox
Christianity does which will yield
knowledge about the human condition and
about God so now coming back in Chapter
2 to the second stage he says here we're
going to argue against those who falling
from the Second Step entertain wrong
sentiments respecting the supreme god
what are these with respect to anger
some saying either does a kindness to
anyone nor becomes angry others take
away anger but leave to God kindness so
the philosophers wind up being agreed on
the subject of anger but they're at
variance regarding kindness and he said
okay I'm going to deal with these and
that's what we see them doing in the
rest of the work
there is one other thing that we should
mention in relation to this so you know
God is helping human beings to you know
use the faculty of reason that they were
given more fully and to avoid falling
into some of the mistakes that the
non-Christian philosophers even though
they're you know relatively wise
compared to other human beings the
mistakes that they're making by
following up conjectures
so you know if we look at chapter seven
this is a particularly uh interesting
one
he's comparing human beings to the as
you call it the brute animals the
animals that are different than us that
we say are lacking in rationality and he
actually goes on to say well
you know we want to say that human
beings are distinct from the other
animals by being this or this or this
but you know the other animals kind of
participate in that so if you look at
what he he says
um he says speech is peculiar to human
beings even in the animals there's a
certain resemblance to speech right
laughter is also peculiar to human
beings but we see certain indications of
joy and other animals what is so
peculiar to human beings as reason and
the foreseeing of the future
but there are animals which open several
outlets in different directions from
their layers seems like they're engaged
in some intelligence and reflection some
problem solving other animals are
Provident for the future so what really
is distinctive to us human beings it's
not just rationality it's something that
you could say incorporates rationality
and develop it further and that is
wisdom wisdom is what is distinctive to
human beings and you know he'll talk
later on about God giving us wisdom
that's a capacity that we have and it
has to do with uh judging good and evil
right now this as he is going to assert
is going to be connected with God
he says he brings up Cicero on this
account there's no animal and Cicero
says except the human being that has any
knowledge of God the human being alone
is furnished with wisdom so that the
human being alone understands religion
this is the chief or only difference
between human being and the dumb animals
wisdom and religion this capacity to as
we could say learn from incorporate what
it is that God wants us to know so that
we're not stuck in ignorance or
semi-learned ignorance like the
philosophers who don't have the
advantages of being you know taught and
connected with uh God so you know we
need to rely upon that if we want to
make progress particularly when it comes
to understanding the nature of the
Divine and we can zero in on specific
problems like you know does God get
angry or not if God does why does God
get angry how does God get angry those
are things that the pre-christian
philosophers according to lachtancius
couldn't really make adequate progress
with but
going up these these gradations these
steps towards greater knowledge uh aided
by God human beings can in fact properly
understand and so this is a prime
example of what we might call Applied
Christian philosophy